[Music]
hi everyone my name is Vadim I work as
an engineer at da da da
let me read so I'll be talking about a
service that we had been working for a
year and a half that replaced a
different service so a little bit about
data dog itself we a monitoring company
we provide monitoring for different
things from hardware service to
databases web servers we collect
application performance monitoring
metrics logs and etc and obviously we
alert but no worries the talk is not
gonna be about data dog at all this is
like a little bit of content like that
I'm gonna go through and first of all
for those who arrived to New York
welcome to New York it's been waiting
for you back to serious problems this is
a lag description of the data that we
have we capture like or godis metric ids
some x x values and this goes through a
certain map that distributes the
payloads to top kafka topics and
partitions so a certain metric will
always go to a certain topic and
partition and from there different
topics and partitions are consumed by a
host or a single consumer and then this
consumer rewrites data to different
files one file per metric ID and after
that it encodes and compresses and
writes custom binary files to s3 every X
hours this whole system powers
historical metrics at data dogs are once
you go on dashboards older than one day
the system is going to use files
produced by that system the problem with
that original system is that one house
has hard limit on the number of file
descriptors which is 1 million so once
we hit a 1 million of file descriptors
we have to split topics and partitions
across new posts and new consumers and
for that we had to set timestamps when
new must start consuming all stop
consuming and so on and
manual process is really prone to
mistakes the other problem is that once
you have like a host having like high CP
usage you split it and you have a couple
houses that have like 50% utilization
and you basically pain
extra money for some resources that you
are not going to use until you ramp up
like your topics and partitions and the
other problem is hmm once you go to one
partition per host and you hit like 1
million of file descriptors you
basically have no room to upscale and if
you're no dice you have to start a new
instance reset Kafka offsets replay data
for the past X hours and that's a huge
manual process the other part that is
difficult is that it's difficult to
predict like which organ metric is going
to be big so this system creates some
hot big topics and partitions which
creates problems downstream so we
decided to create a new system that new
service that automatically balances orgs
and metrics across different topics and
partitions so each kafka topic partition
is equally sized but that means that we
now have to consume all the data and we
don't know like in which exactly
partition our metric metric is stored so
out of this we got requirements to the
new system conceptually it must work
with the new partition and schema it
must be able to handle 10x growth if we
grow like twice if we double our size of
data every year it must work for the
next three years we got we have to keep
the cost of the same level as the
existing system which was a little bit
tricky and it must be as fast as the
existing system which is also tricky but
besides conceptual problems conceptual
requirements we had operational Mis
operational requirements so the system
must be easily scalable without much
manual intervention it
we should minimize impact on Kafka we
should reduce the data retention time it
should be still be able to replay data
easily and in case we have some bug
so a data dog before starting new
service overall we always create
document outlining everything that we're
gonna implement and then we request
comments and as you can see if this
document was started in June even half
ago pretty much and we got some feedback
and we discussed before even starting
working on anything here is a quote from
Taylor sweet Swift sorry
we need to load all topics partitions to
compose a single time series why not
upload Kafka to somewhere and then load
the whole data set with SPARC this is
really insightful quote and we did
exactly that so going back to the
previous model that we had so as you can
see file descriptors encoding and
compressing and writing and this part we
have state and we have compute separate
so what we want to do is we want to
store cough cut to some storage which
will be state and then we want to load
storage and do all the computations
which is compute and the technologies
that we decided to use is Kafka Connect
and spark so Kafka Connect would just
get data from Kafka and stored to
history and then as we would laud it as
if we were reading Kafka and out of this
was born the name of the project taylor
s so it Taylor's secondary resolution
data in our files so that's why we call
it tell res cool I'm not going to talk a
lot about Kafka Connect but basically
it's a simple consumer that writes data
to as three as ease without any
modifications every 10 minutes
and the goal is like to deliver data to
s3 as fast as possible on the graph you
can see that we write lots of files
every 10 minutes
if Kafka connect is really easy to
operate
we just need to update single config if
you want to add new topics or remove
some topics if we change the number of
partitions it will handle everything
automatically removing and adding
workers is super easy
Kafka connect rebalances itself and
because we write files every 10 minutes
we commit offsets every 10 minutes it
means that if we want to stop the system
we'll only push back us ten minutes so
we can reduce Kafka retention the other
part that was tricky about Kafka Connect
is we had to fine-tune memory and
overall so here you can see the process
itself uses about 27 gigabytes and the
heap stays about 16 so about like 10
gigs is used for other of heap
operations such as Network IO
compression decompression and other
parts which you normally don't see if
you just look at the heap we also make
sure that our nodes loaded we don't have
like idle workers but overall like
balancing workers is still unsolved
problems we write every 10 minutes a lot
of data
I actually was told to remove y-axis
here but it's in terabytes basically so
that's a lot of data and because of that
we had to do a lot of optimizations so
we had to run them randomized key
prefixes to avoid having had underline
as three partitions we know that a table
yes recently announced like a year ago
that they solve this problem and we
actually thought that they solved but
turns out they did not and we had to
implement randomization we implemented
paralyzed multi-part uploads because our
recipes were mostly idle when we were
just using single threaded uploads and
we submitted pull request to confluent
but it was not yet accepted we figured
out like optimal size of buffers to
avoid out of memory issues with that we
had before without and we discovered
them by monitoring the system and we
still have lots of slowdown errors from
sv so we have exponential back-off for
that and we monitor retries and here's
like taylor swift points this is like
shows like the number of points we
process the other part after like we
solve the problem the part with storage
and saving the state we had to load all
this the whole Kafka basically for eight
hours or even more in SPARC and there
are lots of unknowns reading ten
and points is very difficult you're
gonna have lots of objects so you need
to somehow minimize garbage collection
if you need to figure out how to utilize
internal ApS of spark to get like the
squeeze all the juices out of spark is
it even possible this spark like I
remember one of the first conversation
with my team man Tim lead like I was
like I don't know like maybe it's not
possible and make it cost-efficient
that's another part like you can read
like 10 trillion points but at what cost
right so minimizing garbage collection
we had to reuse lots of objects this is
one of the examples that we've done so
we allocate one megabyte byte buffer
once we open a file we keep decoding
payloads we compress them using the STD
into the allocated memory so in one
megabyte block and then we get data from
this same byte buffer so we only
allocated by buffer once and keep
reusing it the other part is we use data
frame API extensively because Park
allows you to bypass completely creating
objects since part knows how to handle
like its own internal memory
representations but for that like to be
as close as possible to the data frames
we wanted to create a data frame
compatible file format so we created it
it provides the reader of internal roads
and then of this internal raw points to
the regions of memory in the allocated
buffer from previous slide so this is an
example of like what it actually does so
this whole thing is the code that spark
generated so for some stages it
generates code Java code and execute it
so here you get internal row and then
from this internal row it gets integers
from special specific positions and
inside our reader we have just a single
row the same object and then when
somebody calls get integer we know fill
position and we then we just slide
within the byte buffer and get
everything so here we avoided creating
lots of objects and we directly deliver
primitives to the SPARC internal memory
we did some profiling which
didn't help us much to be honest I don't
actually remember what I was profiling
on these screenshots but I just through
them like we did it here's an after like
we created a file format and word
replaced the previous method with
datasets as you can see like the tasks
time overall a 700 hours went down to
400 and the most important part is
garbage collection dropped like by three
times that's not the other problem we
had is that Kafka connects sometimes
creates really big files bigger than two
gigabytes and inspark
in java overall you cannot have but byte
arrays bigger than two gigabytes and and
overall like if you try to read like 30
files of two gigabytes in memory you're
gonna use like 60 gigabytes which is not
great so instead what we do is we copy a
file locally and then we do some weed
memory and map it into the virtual
memory is in a library from indeed and
then we allocate empty buffer by buffer
using Java reflections and then we point
by buffer to that region of memory
inside the memory map file and then we
give this byte buffer to the STD to
decompress and everything thinks that
it's just by buffer but this actually
points to memory map file so this is a
example of some unsaved memory
manipulations that we had to do in order
to completely bypass creation of
unnecessary objects and really like to
give my files the other part is that
some files get really big so when you
have like multiple tasks running some of
them will be completely skewed so
instead of that we wanted to our file
format to be split able as well so we
said split size of one gigabyte so
multiple readers are gonna read like
different parts of the file and inside
will write inside the file we write
lengths payload length payload leg
length payload so when a reader starts
reading it it has like start position
and end position and it gives keeping
payloads until it reaches the start by
it super simple
and because of lots of tricks with
allocation de-allocation of memory we
had to sorry we had to do we had to
implement fine-grained monitoring around
that so we attract like how much memory
we allocated how much memory we do
allocate it and as you can see here we
our code is pretty efficient so we only
use like four gigabytes of Max or each
executors the other part that I was
talking about using spark internal api's
so you have data set map it must create
objects it copies primitives from spark
memory it has chemo which is great it it
is type safe which is also great but it
is slow because of the first two parts
what instead we do is we use query
execution to RDD which returns internal
raw but it doesn't create objects it's
just a single internal raw the same
object so it's pretty much the same
trick we did in the beginning but now
we're using it like from read inside it
doesn't copy primitives it has no schema
which is not great at all and it's not
type safe so you can shoot yourself in
the leg and internal row has direct
access to spark memory so here is how we
do it so here we have our data frame we
do some operations and then once we
create this data frame we do core
execution to RGD will get internal raw
and then we have to get fields using
filled indexes so we had to do also lots
of testing around that we did some also
like settings to off heap so as here as
you can see at max we use about like 180
gigabytes but the off hip itself is
about like 60 so 120 gigabytes is used
for lots of heap operations and we did
testing so here we only compare like
garbage collection to tasks time so this
crew shots were taking a look at
different time but basically the first
one you can see like almost half of the
execution time is spent on garbage
collection and once we enabled off heap
on the like maybe a fourth fifth so
everything is great
and this is a real production job so
here we load like 22 terabytes and
test time is like a thousand and garbage
collection only like 70 60 hours so only
six percent and in real were in actual
on the real class where we run multiple
jobs and the garbage collection is even
lower it's below one percent so all
those optimizations led to removing like
garbage collection basically I'm sorry
thanks testing unit tests are boring we
have them there's lots of references to
Taylor Swift as well integration tests
we have them also like 1989 stage
environment we have it so I'm not going
to talk about it we did load test since
lowest parts checking data correctness
and game days so I'm gonna be talking
about those parts so load testing once
we had a working prototype we started
throwing more data at the our job so we
threw like 10x more data and we check
like what parts are breaking what are
the slowest parts insert etcetera and we
were estimating costs so as our company
grows like how expensive it is going to
be linear
exponential or something else slowest
parts we got to have you always have to
have good and the standard of slowest
parts of your job so you would know when
it's gonna break when you have to start
optimizing it and so on so knowing
limits is really important and we report
lots of metrics about parts that we
think a slow or fast and we also have
historical data so we can paralyze house
stages become slower faster and this
reporter also prints ASCII portrait of
Taylor Swift every time we run it so
after we ran the new system using all
the data that we have we did one-to-one
joined with previous system so you have
like 10 trillion points on one side and
then trillion points on the other side
which was another problem to join but
this allowed us to find some edge cases
that we were able to eliminate so out of
like trillions of points you see like
less than 1% had a difference and we
were
like why is that and turns out like when
we were reading we had to recreate the
same positions of points so you have
like point with the same timestamp but
within Kafka topic they were like
scrambled after eliminating this issue
we were able to completely element
eliminate any differences pretty much
game days game days for those that are
familiar created to test your system how
how resilient it is what is like limits
and fault tolerance and so on so you
come up with scenarios so you can kill
an O to kill the whole service you make
a note like slow or like differ like
different different scenarios you least
like expected results the you then run
scenarios and you write down what
happened and then you summarize key
lessons so for example here we were
killing the whole note we expected some
things to happen some things happened
something didn't here's like we were
like slowing down a note artificially
and out of this it all allowed us to
figure out like do we need monitoring of
certain parts do we need to invest like
new tooling and so on and also allowed
us a lot of other people to get familiar
with the system overall charting once we
confirm that our prototype works using
the whole volume of DNA we decided to
split the job into shards so there were
like multiple reasons so we use part
instances so losing a single job for a
shard will not result into losing the
whole progress and if for some reason
there is an edge case it will only
affect a single shirt so your job pool
other jobs will pass but this chart will
be affected so you can limit the scope
of your problem and ability to process
parts two completely separate on
completely separate shirts
sorry clusters so sometimes like in your
availability zone you will not have
available instances so you can start in
a separate availability zone and process
data from s3 because it's its multi easy
replicated so before implement ensuring
we had to identify independent blocks of
data
so in our case it was simply orgs so
because one or it doesn't depend on
other org we were able to like split
them completely and on the Kafka connect
site we just have like config files that
spreads them across like 64 64 share
charts or if org is it is really big we
can move it to a separate chart so and
because we know a single job can process
all the data that we have and now we
have a single chart that's like 64 times
smaller it means that our job overall if
we continue Dublin data it will work for
the next like six years and after which
we can increase number of shirts after
we did all the testing and all the
preparations we had to start like
migrations migrations is really
difficult so in order to replace
existing system we had to do multiple
things first of all we wanted to run
both systems alongside we needed a
release plan and roll back a rollback
plan we needed to make sure that systems
that depend on our data can work with
both new and old and we had we wanted to
also do partial migrations of customers
so if like new system is not producing
like correct data only a subset of
customers will be affected we needed to
check everything under line pipelines
and everything else and finally we had
to do a final migration so to run both
system alongside we wanted to run them
as close as possible to production same
volume of data we wanted to output in
completely separate locations so nobody
uses this data but the whole system runs
like as if if in production we make sure
we made sure that there is no
discrepancies with existing data and we
treated every incident as a real
production incident so there was like
on-call rotation and everything and we
were writing post mortems as usual but
nobody was using our data we were just
like getting familiar with the system
this approach allowed us find
bottlenecks that we previously didn't
see our new BOTS we figured it out like
what kind of monitoring we were missing
and we got people
familiar with this whole system and how
to operate it without affecting
production and yeah we figured out some
additional tools that we needed release
plans to enroll by rollback plans for
every important for every pretty much
every piece of the whole system and
underlying system we had did we have
really detailed plans how to deploy and
how to roll back as you can see on
deploy here we checked all the boxes and
we didn't need rollback plan likely so
for dependent systems we wanted to
switch customers tune to the new system
and back in case of problems we wanted
to for dependent pipelines to be able
still to load both datasets and see like
nothing happened and yeah that's what I
said
oh and we wanted to make sure that if
you have like a dependent pipeline
running using new data it will have the
same output as if you were running it
using all data partial integration of
customers it's very expensive to run
both systems alongside when you have
like system that burns like millions of
dollars you you know you want to run it
like it'll taste like six month you're
gonna burn a lot of money so we wanted
to just migrate like some customers so
we wanted to migrate our org so it a
data dog we use data dog to monitor data
dog we one of the biggest customers of
data dog so what's natural for us to
like move us and see like oh hey what's
up so we wanted to do to a four month
and then after months we wanted to move
like a certain customer but the problem
was like lots of lots of parts were not
ready for that so like lots of parts
didn't know that like there will be
partial migrations usually like when you
do migration you do like to swap right
no we had to like come up with like
system that is going to offer like a
certain time stamp it will start stop
writing in the old system and then will
start writing in the new system and so
on it was difficult to implement and
maintain migration times times for each
org certain things didn't have
versioning so we had to add it
and for downstream pipelines everything
must look like nothing happened so that
you you're not gonna touch like every
pipeline you have you somehow have to
create like some mechanism that's gonna
work for that and we had to do lots of
integration tests with migration time
steps so the integration tests that we
had helped us and over like for all the
pipelines that we have we have
integration tests so it was pretty much
pretty easy to check if migration time
stamps are gonna work and after that it
was pretty easy we picked a date added
additional integration tests tested on
staging rolled in production we let the
old system run for a week and we killed
the old system and we cleaned out all
the code actually we haven't cleaned up
all code but that's in this future
results so here's a comparison of the
old system so it was like everything
storage compute was everything indeed
inside the system you can see after
Connect compute calls is 13% s3 is 39%
so basically storing kafka spark is 77%
and if you summarize those numbers you
actually get number 129 so it's it's
more expensive which is understandable
once you offload the state and load it
you will have to spend more compute a
resources all right you have to
serialize serialize send Network etc etc
but because we were able to remove a lot
of data from Kafka we in total we
actually way cheaper than the old system
so we actually save lots of money and
the speed so here you can see that we
prepare data within like 10 hours so we
we all write files within 10 hours after
like the point appeared and here we had
some outage life happens
so result in higher level the new system
works with the new partition in schema
it handles 10x growth it we keep the
cost at the same level as the existing
system and actually cheaper and it's as
fast as the existing system operational
it scales
without much manual intervention so
kafka connect we just add additional
workers on spark side side we just add
additional executors and as Regis
elastic cloud right we minimize impact
on Kafka we reduce data retention in
Kafka a lot and we actually store Kafka
data in sweet longer two times longer so
we actually increase retention in a
sense we still able to replay data
easily we actually had to replay Kafka
Connect and spur jobs many times and we
actually had game names game days where
we were replaying some Kafka connect
data so we were sure that everything
works and here's a graph of page of duty
incidence in hours so the green one is
the old system the blue one is Kafka
Connect and the purple one is a spark
job and we completely switched all
system in October and as you can see the
old system had lots of lots of troubles
so overall in in terms of apps we also
won and in conclusion what I want to
reiterate is that documents and plants
and RFC's are really helpful we document
a lot of things we discussed lots of
things without like doing stuff spending
time so that's definitely something that
everybody should be doing now we did
lots of testing which helped us a lot we
did load tests we did like integration
tests everything
migrations are difficult unfortunately I
don't have like like silver bullet for
that like the migrations will always be
difficult I think and there were many
engineering obstacles that we were able
to solve our bait life some of like the
methods that we use are really
unconventional and we were constantly
monitoring we were constantly checking
our forecasts about the cost and speed
new system because like if you build
like expensive new system like you're
probably not going in the right
direction so we actually we're doing
forecasts and estimates like every month
while we were working for like a year
and a half and this is pretty much it
this is my work email personal
Twitter and venmo if somebody wants to
send me thank you for listening and
[Applause]
[Music]